president trump spoke with vice
president pence for the first time
since the attack the two met yesterday
at the white house
just days after the president's
supporters called for mr pence's
murder and as the vice president faces
calls
to use the 25th amendment to force
president trump
from office now speaker nancy pelosi has
given the vice president
until tomorrow to make his decision
while she moves ahead with possible
impeachment plans against the president
nancy cordes is on capitol hill so what
happens next nancy
well what's next anthony is that the
house votes tonight to urge the vice
president to invoke the 25th
amendment that is the first step in a
process but it is unlikely
to yield results because white house
sources tell cbs news that the vice
president is not going to do
anything to force mr trump out
the house will be in order house
democrats will try to
up the pressure on the vice president
today passing a resolution
calling on him and the cabinet to
declare
president donald j trump incapable of
executing the duties of his office
and to immediately exercise powers as
acting president
the vote to impeach will likely come
tomorrow
and the leaders of that push are already
getting explicit threats
you're out of your mind you haven't seen
anything yet
the impeachment resolution argues
president trump
gravely endangered the security of the
united states last week
we fight like hell california's ted lou
is one of the resolutions
authors he incited a mob that attacked
the capital resulting
in numerous deaths we can't just pretend
this did not happen
in a letter to house republicans gop
leader kevin mccarthy argued
against impeachment in favor of
something less severe such as
censure but some of his gop colleagues
will likely vote to impeach
michigan republican peter meyer it is
obvious that the president
is no longer qualified to hold that
office if impeachment passes in the
house tomorrow that means the senate
could be gearing up for a trial
just as president-elect biden prepares
to take office
west virginia democrat joe manchin
argues the votes
aren't there to convict i think this is
so ill-advised for joe biden to be
coming in
trying to heal the country trying to be
the president of all the people when
we're going to be so divided and
fighting again
mr biden has been discussing the timing
with democratic leaders
you go half day on dealing with the
impeachment and half day getting my
people nominated and confirmed in the
senate
senate democrats would need at least 17
republicans to join with them to convict
but so far
only one republican senator has said
he'll consider impeachment while two gop
senators
have called on the president to resign
today mr trump will be traveling to
alamo texas to tout the completion
of part of his signature border wall
it's the first time we'll see him
in public since the white house released
a video of him
last thursday gail it will be
interesting to see if he has anything to
say
thank you very much nancy